from wendy's to quiznos we wanted to
find out all the biggest portion size
differences between uk and u.s fast food
this is food wars
in the uk wendy's iconic frosties come
in three sizes junior regular and large
in the us we actually have four frosty
sizes junior small medium large
we're going to pour out the largest
frosty to see how big it is compared to
the us's
the classic hamburger at a wendy's is
called a dave's named after the founder
dave thomas ours come in singles doubles
and triples our burgers are the same in
the uk they also come as singles doubles
or triples now we're gonna weigh a us
triple pretty close 14 ounces for our
triple now while the triple might be the
official limit on burger sizes at
wendy's wendy's enthusiasts have come up
with something called a meat cube this
is a secret menu item where you actually
take an extra meat patty and add it to
this so you get four patties which i
think adds up to around a pound joe i'm
officially challenging you to a meat
cube showdown the fastest person to eat
the entire meatkeep wins you think you
got it i accept your challenge harry
let's do this three
and one start
[Music]
i wish i had more time to chew it
need the sauce
need some moisture
the buns
[Music]
usa baby ah terrible
i feel absolutely terrible and yet
elated that i won well now we know why
the u.s has such an obesity problem
okay that's quite enough of that
back to our regularly scheduled
programming another iconic wendy's menu
item is the baconator in the uk these
just come in one size as a regular of
course in the us we also have the
baconator but we have a smaller
baconator known as the son of baconator
something incredibly unsettling about a
burger having a child that's also a
burger
this baconator giving birth to that
baconator and of course we're gonna
weigh the regular baconators to see
who's this bigger the highly regarded
wendy's nuggets that come in regular or
spicy love the spicy they come in units
of four six and ten
nuggets in the uk only come in two
portion sizes four and eight
wendy's of course has fries and those
fries in the us come in four sizes
junior small medium large our fries also
come in four sizes value small medium
and large let's wear our large fries to
see who's getting more
ours is way less
hmm
another side that is probably unique to
wendy's i can't think of any other fast
food place that does this is wendy's
chili it has been on the menu since it
opened back in 1969.
in the u.s you can get your chili
for whatever reason in two sizes small
and large in the uk we only have one
size of chili which is this one we're
gonna wear against the largest size in
the us to find the difference
finally let's compare drinks in the u.s
you can get three sizes of drink small
medium and large on the internet it does
not specify
how much fluid ounces are in any of
these
i've had to guess
too much way too much
way way too much in the uk drinks come
in three sizes small medium or large and
these are advertised as being 12 16 and
20 ounces respectively let's measure the
larger strengths to see which countries
is bigger
so our large drink actually came out as
close to 18 ounces than closer to 20. i
will say that in the uk you fill up your
own drink so maybe i just needed to fill
a bit more okay so their large is 18
ounces what is our small
20 ounces so our small is bigger than
their large
man we love drinking our calories in
this country
the fountain drinks of popeyes come in
three sizes the small which is 22 ounces
the medium which is 30 ounces
and the large which is
of course
40 ounces
40
ounces
that's so much soda in the uk drinks
only come in two sizes as a kids size or
as a regular size we're not sure how
much is in either of these so we're
going to measure them both a little over
300
about 450.
but those aren't the biggest i say
actually at the popeyes of the us you
can also get a gallon of sweet tea
an unsweetened tea
one whole
gallon
oh look at this
gallon gallon oh and don't you hate when
dummies do that thing where they're like
hey the medium is a sound same size as
the large and it never is it's like
telecon so medium soda large cup
oh wow guys
the medium is about the same size as the
large except for like oh i don't know 10
ounces dump tick tockers you guys
out of your league tick tockers i'm the
fast food king online
all right
when was this clean last
oh
i'm gonna go 36 what do you think i mean
it could have been the amount the top of
this cup but again you can't
fill this to the brim you have to put a
cap on it in the uk fries just come as a
regular serving the u.s we got two
popeyes fries sizes uh regular and large
the regular as we have here just came
with the side of the three piece we got
here and of course a large which is a
box of just fries we're gonna weigh
these to see how they compare to the u.s
we of course now are going to also weigh
our largest fry
do not sleep on these fries
you'll be surprised to learn that the
inside of the scale is disgusting a
popeye's chicken sandwich in the uk
weighs
exactly 250 grams
in the u.s it weighs
270 grams
in the u.s popeye's signature chicken
comes in seven serving sizes we'll start
with these so of course the one piece
kids meal then you can upgrade to a
two-piece regular meal which comes with
a side and a biscuit or you get yourself
the three piece and a four-piece
side and a biscuit
from there you can get yourself an
eight-piece family meal the 12 piece for
the family as well
or just for one person over a weekend
and the largest the 16 piece are you
kidding me
how absurd is this look at all this
chicken
in the uk the signature chicken comes as
a two-piece meal as a three-piece meal
or as a six-piece sharer as a nine-piece
sharer or a larger size the 12-piece
sharer let's weigh a wing a thigh and a
leg to see whose chickens are bigger
so in the uk our thigh leg and wing
combo came to around 290 grams
here we go first guy up
the leg
next up got
[Music]
kind
that
wing
wimpy looking one and this one the thai
how about the tendes in the us we have
these following sizes a kid's meal has a
one piece
but what's up they gave us two
and then from there you get a three
piece which they forgot
and then we have
five piece comes to the side in a
biscuit eight pieces i feel like they're
getting bigger as i go along look at the
size of this tender then we have the 12
piece i mean guys this is like a look at
this did you know they're this big this
is fantastic i love how big these are
that's what i'm talking about popeyes
thank you and of course the 16 piece
look at this bad boy look at the size of
these guys
tenders in the uk come in four portion
sizes there's a two piece which is a
kids meal there's a three piece a five
piece
and an eight piece
next up is the nuggets these can be
found in servings of a four piece kids
meal a six piece kids meal eight piece
the 12 piece
24 piece
36 pieces
and then
this double pile right here
the biggest order 48 pieces and i have
to say
does not look like enough
i know i could destroy that 48 piece
with
confidence
let's see we got here oh look at this
sticker this is fun yeah look at these
guys this big one playing a saxophone
how fun is that
that's cool right in the uk we actually
call our nuggets bites and they come in
the following sizes there's a four piece
which is a kids meal a six piece a nine
piece and a twelve piece unfortunately
we couldn't get these today usa we got
biscuits baby
these are the not cookie biscuits that
have come up before in other food wars
episodes these are the biscuits biscuits
and a popeyes you can get them in one
either on its own or probably just about
every meal you can also get them in
six it's like rolling right down here
and you can also get them in twelve
just overflowing biscuits over here
we actually do have biscuits on the uk
popeyes menu if you order it as a side
you get one biscuit
in the uk jollibee serves their famous
chicken joy in six portion sizes
starting with
a one piece in the u.s you can get your
chicken joy in five different portions
a one piece with a side next up we've
got a two piece
a two piece
also with a side we move to a three
piece a three piece that comes with a
side i'm so excited to try this is my
first ever taste of jollibee fried
chicken
now my first time harry
oh that's good that was really good
i don't know how it stayed so crispy the
next size is up our buck is a chicken
you can get a bucket in six
or
bucket of 10. buckets from a uk jollibee
come in three sizes starting with a six
piece
then from there we move up to an eight
piece bucket
and last but by no means least our
biggest portion size is a bucket of 12.
should have got a bigger plate
it's really good
i just love chicken this is a good
example
[Music]
these little crispy bits that fall off
your chicken gold dust
let's each weigh our six piece buckets
to see if the chicken joint in one
country is bigger than the other it's
time for some jenga
ah we have over a hundred grams more
chicken
i realize this is so arbitrary the size
of the meats
uh the amount of coding but it's nice to
win
regardless the chicken at jollibee also
comes in the form of tenders in the uk
these are served in four portion sizes
as a single tender one one piece one
piece who's getting one chicken tender
that's two tenders
there's a portion of three tenders
and finally
as a portion of four
one chicken tender i've never heard of
that anywhere well here in america we
have normal portion sizes for our
chicken tenders you get them in three
pieces
six pieces i think three is not enough
but okay three pieces
six pieces
10 pieces
or
16.
yeah
tenders how do you like that
there's a little bit more going on now i
like it a little bit of heat to it the
batter seems different it has more of
like the buttermilk flavor to it i like
the coating
oh garlic man
always
he needs ranch when you have garlic mass
who needs garlic mayo when you have
ranch
ranch is far superior to garlic mayo no
question
oh yeah i love ranch
a worthy addition ranch is way better
herbs and spices aren't they like
basically the same thing
then we're also some jollibee
specialties now one iconic dish is this
one this is the jolly spaghetti now this
is a dish made of spaghetti with some
cheese as well as a sweet style sauce
which is i think made with like banana
ketchup and some meat as well and then
it's topped with hot dog slices in the
uk this only comes as one portion size
it's a cute size you got there harry but
here in the us we have three sizes a
regular portion
our family portion
and the party portion look at this this
is supposed to be eight to ten people
it's like a lasagna look at that
now according to a friend of mine from
the philippines the pro move is to dunk
the chicken into the spaghetti sauce so
let's give that a try
cheese like the cold cheese
isn't doing any favors i'll be honest
okay yeah that's actually not bad it's a
bit misleading because there's spaghetti
is actually the sauce is sweet very good
yeah together that's really good then
we're onto the burgers now jollibee is
famous for its yum burgers which is a
beef burger with its signature tiger
sauce in the uk these come as either a
single or as a double over here in the
us you can get the classic yum burger or
this the double yum burger
don't want to bun for your burger you
say jollibee has you covered they have
something called the burger steaks
patties of burgers smothered in their
mushroom gravy you can get them in two
patties
three patties or the six patty family
pack over here the burger steaks only
come as a two piece in the u.s you can
get a side of white rice we only have
one size and there's this one right here
same here our rice just comes in one
portion and it's wrapped up like this
very cute
[Music]
let's start with the starters now tgi
fridays in the uk and the us both have
lots of starter options so what we're
going to do is pick the most popular
ones and compare those first up we have
the mozzarella sticks
an order of these in the uk contains
four sticks
in the u.s our tgi friday's mozzarella
sticks come in an order of six six
sticks or you can get the platter which
doubles that
12 sticks
we're gonna weigh three uk mozzarella
sticks to try and find the average
weight
hey harry is that three sticks
i thought we uh thought that order had
four
so three mozzarella sticks in the uk
weighed 95 grams that means that each
individual mozzarella stick weighed an
average of 31.6 grams
yes
so six sticks is 260 grams so that's
roughly 43 point repeating three grams
per stick
now pro tip weigh your food
[Music]
then try one
[Music]
cheese fries is running right in the
mozzarella cheese stick game the running
the mad stick game
the uk does have loaded potato skins but
they're not currently serving them due
to the pandemic because they don't
travel very well for delivery however we
were able to find some in the store when
they are available in the restaurants
they come in serving sizes of 6 or 12.
well we didn't have that problem in the
us or maybe we just don't care either
way loaded potato skins are totally
available at the ustgi fridays and they
come in two sizes you can get them eight
or you get the platy boy which is 12.
chicken wings in the uk come in two
portion sizes
as a single portion of three wings
or as a sharing portion
which is six wings
harry when i said to compare the wings
between the us and the uk i meant these
wings maybe it's cultural differences or
maybe i just read the menu wrong
anyway
in the u.s our wings come in an order of
10 or you can get a platter of either 30
or 50 wings
hell yeah dude i want to eat every
single one of these wings
if you like your chicken off the bone
you can also get boneless wings at tgi
fridays in both the uk and the us here
they come in two portion sizes as a
single which is seven ounces or as a
sharing size which is 14 ounces
in the u.s our tgi fridays offer
boneless wings by ounces you can get 10
ounces 40 ounces or a platter of 80
ounces
look at this you have no idea how good
this smells
so good
how is it so good
the ribs in the uk come in two sizes as
a half rack or as a full rack and both
come in either a legendary or a barbecue
place
our ribs in the u.s also come in a half
slab or a full slab
we're gonna wear a large portion to see
who out of me or joe has the biggest
rack
[Music]
so a large rack of ribs in the uk came
to around 366 grams
a bunch of children over there
joe's rack grow up
all right here we go
oh
this guy's already falling apart
tender and a full slab in the u.s is
almost 600 grams how do you like that i
got the bigger rack
most meals in the uk come with a side of
fries by default so we're gonna weigh a
regular portion of fries to see what it
comes to
yikes ours is only 120 120 for a side of
fries in the us
in the uk nando's chicken comes in three
serving sizes
quarter of a chicken in the u.s nando's
standard chicken comes in just two sizes
there's a half a chicken
a whole chicken
or a fourth of a chicken
you can get a whole chicken in the u.s
but only as part of a platter and we're
going to weigh the whole chicken to see
which country's chickens are bigger usa
chicken baby
we can also get boneless thighs in the
uk if you order these they come in a
portion of four our thighs actually come
with a portion of three so we got one
two three
chicken chicken wings
they're my favorite thing and i love to
sing if you haven't already seen it look
up the nando's skank
which is a very pure distillation of
british culture in the late northeast
it's ed sheeran an example rapping
rapping about nando's in a car park i
don't know why and then he's just
flexing his black card which i'm feeling
about because you know nando's black
card uh
they give them out to select individuals
and it entitles you to free nando's
which i'm so jealous of also bone to
pick with that in general why do they
always give the celebrities the free
stuff because other people you need at
least they're already rich sort of guy
out come on
i'm not a celebrity
not yet next up in the uk we've got
wings they come in four portions
a portion of three our wings come as a
serving of 12. a portion of five four a
portion of ten twenty four or a portion
of fifteen
if chicken on the bone isn't for you
nando's also offers chicken in the form
of burgers wraps and pitters in the uk
you can get these as singles
or as doubles
we can also get our chicken wrapped
or burgered
however in the us there's no option to
add double chicken which sucks
it's like a little burrito
holy
don't do food words without eating
breakfast
i'm going to cry
we're going to remove all the toppings
from the single chicken burger and weigh
it to see how it compares to the us
version so we're going to take out the
tomato
and the lettuce
just like
harry mentioned
which is good because tomato does not
belong on burgers and never should
on the side of your chicken it's pretty
common to get some chips at nando's i'm
excited for this episode because i can
actually call them chips for once as
that's what they're referred to on the
us menu suck it joe suck it joel what
did i do why is everyone telling me
he's not even hosting this episode i
just can't
send for him chips in the uk come in
regular or large sizes the standard us
sizes are regular and large
however if you get them as part of a
platter you can get the bonus extra
large size
let's weigh the large fries to see whose
is bigger
maybe i should have used the bowl
oh no
i'm still gonna eat these i don't care
if they touch all these gross
i'm getting too good at emptying brick
chips from containers so our scale is
just about adequate for this one and a
portion of large fries in the uk i said
fries why do i say fries i'm being
conditioned to saying fries that's right
buddy i heard you say fries this show is
getting to me a portion of large chips
in the uk comes to about 498 grams 150
grams
in the uk quiznos sandwiches come in
four sizes firstly we have the kids size
which is four and a half inches then we
have a small sub which is six inches a
medium sub from the uk quiznos is nine
inches or at least it should be before
we got hungry and ate it by mistake and
then finally we have a large sub which
is 12 inches or one foot long in the us
our quizno sandwiches come in four sizes
the sami a four inch an eight inch and a
12 inch
and i want to give quiznos props for not
calling this like a sandwich taco or
something really obnoxious
also in the u.s out of quiznos you can
get party platters of either 20 3-inch
sandwiches or 14 flatbreads cut in half
there are no fountain drinks that are
quizzlers in the uk instead we just have
cans and bottles which are 330
milliliters and 500 milliliters
respectively
in the u.s out of quiznos you can get
drinks in three sizes either a bottle
which is 20 ounces the regular also 20
ounces or the large which they did not
have
let's weigh a classic italian foot long
from a quiznos in the uk to see what it
comes to so our scales could just about
handle that it turns out that a footlong
classic italian from a uk quiz knows is
520 grams
in the us quiznos classic footlong
italian is
about like
406
quiznos was one of the first chains to
toast their subs so now let's
arbitrarily compare the toastedness
between our bread and the uk bread
in our extremely precise comparison
metric it looks like the us maybe has
the edge when it comes to toastiness of
the bread the inside of this is
completely soggy and the outside is very
average
in the uk you can get your order in
three portion sizes as a small platter
as a regular platter or as a sandwich
the halal guys in the us your order can
come in three sizes small regular
sandwich
we're gonna weigh a regular platter in
both countries to see whose is the
biggest
it's been so many episodes
why don't we just get bigger scales
bear with us one second
[Music]
first half is about 300 337 grams
three three seven plus three two one six
five
hey
quick maths
this thing we need to wash this thing
it's getting funky in here
here we go the regular
oh fits in perfectly 640.
640 grams it's a full
meal oh man this smells so good
fries in the uk only come in one portion
size this one in the u.s the halal guys
also only have one size fries oh this
case
seen this do you think it's keeping
crispy so don't get soggy
very smart very innovative i want to eat
this so badly we're going to weigh it
first this could be another brick
hey
so a side of fries from uk halal guys
came to 213 grams
wait
oh yeah okay
yeah
145 grams for one size of halal guys
fries
oh yeah
yo i've never gotten the fries these are
good and crispy don't sleep in the halal
guys fries
in the uk a side of hummus only comes in
one size and it's this one right here
in the us of a tall guy's hummus only
comes in one size and of course we are
going to weigh it
so our side order from this came in at
246 grams i'm going to eat all of this
as soon as the camera stopped rolling a
side order of baba ghanoush in the uk
only comes in one size as well in the
u.s the baba ganoush at the halal guys
is also just one size in the uk you can
get a side of falafel and it comes as a
two-piece serving we did ask for some
but i think the guy forgot so we don't
have any to show you in the us the halal
guys you can get your falafel in three
sizes two pieces four pieces or six
pieces we can also get falafel
sandwiches
let's take some measurements half a
huffle sandwich is eight inches in
diameter and for the moment you've all
been waiting for we're going to measure
the gaff with the tape measure but it's
really not fit to tusk
actually that's that's kind of worked
and our falafel sandwich has a girth of
let's say seven and a bit inches
from
to peta
eight inches
yeah oh look at that
and it's eight inches
thick
eight and eight i like when things are
just precise like that
and finally it weighs
286 grams
and a falafel sandwich at the us halal
guys weighs
like exactly excuse me
exactly 250 grams in the uk if you want
dessert hello guys you can get baklava
it comes in a two-piece serving
of all guys in the u.s the baklava comes
in one size and this one piece this
piece right here
oops i ordered two i guess i'll just
have to eat one oh my god i'm eating
both of these
let's start with the drinks in the uk
the majority of hot drinks only come in
one size which is 12 ounces
pretz says this is to optimize
efficiency and to keep things simple for
customers however there are two
exceptions to this rule
firstly if you order a flat white from a
uk prep
it's served as an eight ounce drink
then if you order an espresso or a
macchiato it comes in one of these
adorable little four ounce cups alright
so in the u.s our hot coffees come in
three sizes
small
medium
and large it's ridiculous
but we also have some exceptions to the
rules
our flat white is only served as an
eight ounce drink but our macchiato is
four ounces like the uk's
and our espresso is actually just two
ounces i guess they're trying to limit
our caffeine intake maybe we're gonna
measure our largest black coffee to find
out if you're actually getting as much
as you told you are
so two perhaps credit that is exactly 12
ounces
we are not getting as much coffee as
they say we are but
maybe that's a good thing 20 is kind of
a lot not getting as much coffee as
advertised hi irene welcome to food wars
what about iced coffees well in the uk
these also just come in one size well
over here we can get ice black coffee as
either a 16 or
24 ounce serving it's a lot of coffee
i don't get people who drink black
coffee
we're both going to measure our largest
ice black coffees to find out what they
come to
so once again this came to exactly 12
ounces so the iced coffee is also
not the advertised amount it's supposed
to be 24 ounces but it looks like it's
only about 21. it's an international
coffee conspiracy
season two we're still dealing with this
i mean is someone gonna do something
about this
once again maybe not a bad thing
it's like a lot of people are gonna
disagree with that do you need this much
caffeine in your life
probably i don't know if joe or harry
drinks this much coffee i feel like joe
might he
he seems like he would he has that
energy joe just looks like he just
drinks like five cups of black coffee a
day and then he's like at like two a.m
haunted
yes i do i drink a lot of coffee i
should say that it's only april and i've
already passed three kidney stones this
year
what about some of the food options this
is an egg salad sandwich from a uk prep
we're going to weigh this one to see how
much it comes to
it's exactly 250 grams maybe our eggs
are heavier
it's all those preservatives if you were
raised here you wouldn't be worried we
should probably be worried
it's not that good but i'm hungry egg
salad is gross
like it generally doesn't taste good but
i'm just taking bites of it so that was
a classic sandwich but what about a
baguette this is a ham and cheese
baguette from a uk prep so our uk ham
and cheeseburger came to exactly 200
grams well here's our famous ham and
cheese baguette it says it should weigh
251 grams
it's exactly 251 grams that's impressive
it's actually kind of scary i know it
should weigh exactly the amount it says
it should but like it's kind of cool
when it actually does
next up we've got this muffin this is a
double berry muffin from a uk prep which
is a blueberry muffin with some extra
blueberry compote in the middle all
right so
we have our classic blueberry muffin
without the extra compo in the middle
let's find out how much it weighs
do you know the muffin man the muffin
man
yes i know the muffin man who lives on
drury lane gotta love shrek can we get a
can we get a hairy shrek
can we get uh harry's face turn into
shrek please you know i've never seen
shrek
my surname is an anagram of shrek